what is up there reject nation we're
gonna watch brooklyn nine-nine
episode three today from season two hey
listen if you end up enjoying the video
why don't you go ahead and hit that like
button
and also uh watch the subscribe click
notification bell you don't follow our
next reactions up and at our patreon we
do full-length watch alongs where you
sing with the time code we cover what
shows over there for the same tier
you get the option for reaction ads and
watch songs included and uh big thanks
to prepper for uh right now these
highlights for us okay guys let's enjoy
the show
[Music]
hey rosa rosa with the swagger can i
have your friend katie's phone number i
want to ask her out no i don't mix
personal and professional i don't have
feelings for amy anymore so
time for me to get out there and spread
my weight legs
uh
legs well either way no not either way
only wings
captain holt and i will have to leave
for a meeting at one police plaza you
should all stay prepped and ready
dismissed the jimmy jab game yeah in
2008 when the king of iraq president
iran arm and jimmy
[Laughter]
jimmy jab seven
circus of fools
jimmy jess jamie
jimmy jabs jimmy dabs jimmy jabs
is that how you plan on sitting
leaning back like a matinee goer
madeline will eat you alive
may i
those are my tissues raymond if you were
planning on sneezing you should have
brought your own
rosa has this dumb rule about not mixing
work with personal stuff that's actually
not a bad policy i once gave my aunt a
jaywalking ticket and things really
deteriorated between us
oh
if i win the jimmy jabs you give me your
number and if i lose you don't have to
give it to me i already don't have to
give it to you all right i'll give you
200 and i'll never ask you for another
phone number again
but
done
realized that i left the tape in the
camera and now it's gone who cares who
cares who cares
you
probably will
oh golly no
oh no
i love that you're trying to step up
your sex game but strength is not your
issue
stop humming and it does not turn me on
when you bend over and back up into me
oh what no
calmly and respectfully prepping all
right they're gone ceremonial bagel
flasks
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a fire hazard absolutely
we play for the phone numbers of rosa's
friends but most importantly we play to
watch amy lose
neither of you have ever come close to
winning you're exactly the same just a
couple of santiagos
our first event is
the mouth-a-thon
in front of you is month-old chinese
food oh damn
[Music]
oh
i can't do this to my mouth she's the
love of my life
oh
i'm out i can do this
i want to win so bad oh great here quick
let me take a picture
oh that's so cute you've got a little
bit of mold on the tip of your nose
oh
it's unbeatable
scully and knew it you guys know this is
free right
hello
lunch of age
human age
sergeant jeffords why don't you just lie
down
oh i can't sit any straighter than this
oh no
giggle pig hmm an embarrassing blight
growing right under your nose not unlike
that mustache you had when we first met
that mustache was era appropriate
[Laughter]
a semicolon it should clearly be a full
colon was this prepared by a recent
immigrant there's a lonely island song
about that request denied i secretly
scheduled us a one-on-one with
madeleine's boss chief bisker i also
split an infinitive and she didn't
notice
[Laughter]
so i accidentally left the tape in there
and i want it back
why what's on it nothing
i just really need it for no
reason i got to get something in return
are you blackmailing me
i don't have any money hitchcock i'm
still paying my uncle's funeral bills
oh
there's one thing i want and it's not
that big i just want you to make me cool
in everyone's eyes
oh no
oh golly
also detective scully has withdrawn due
to food poisoning which i think we all
saw coming all right the second event is
bulky bulky run run the bomb suit foot
rate
because i'm gonna be opening up a lot of
doors for katie on our date oh yeah what
are you doing jake trash talking you
while simultaneously proving that i will
be respectful of your friend it's a
tough line to walk
ruffalo
[Laughter]
i'm doing it charles i look cool
oh no
contestants must craft an undercover
persona and talk to as many police
officers as you can
i think the belly will draw attention
away from my face smart like one big
boob
paul gosler
[Laughter]
i just want to be part of a conversation
where jake uses my name and nobody
insults me damn it you ask too much
poor guy he's kicking so much you want
to feel
no that's a bad idea
oh my baby oh
she crushed it
every time we do dumb games like this
you get all frantic and act like a crazy
idiot my advice next time
don't act like a crazy idiot
i got eliminated
excuse me officer yeah sweetheart
sweetheart seriously hank is how you
talk to women who come in here jimmy
jabs
[Laughter]
damn i thought rosa would win
don't you dare touch amy junior that's
right
it's your baby are you saying i knocked
you up you sure did jake
can i talk to you for a second yeah sure
thing what's happening why she's so
serious beat amy and don't flirt with
her at all
fine easy but you better tell katie to
clear her schedule out thursday for a
date because i am working nights until
then and the following weekend i am out
of town let's do
[Laughter]
when i beat you which victory dance
should i do this one
or this one
[Laughter]
there's a sophie's choice
both are examples of victory dances no
comeback you must be pretty nervous
yep
hey jake hey charles
who's this with me hitchcock
well
we should go now
oh god
i did what you wanted give me the tape
oh no we're not done yet oh next uh i
want you to tell everyone you think i'm
handsome you are a monster
i didn't realize you'd be attending i
can tell you have more of a fly-catching
gate than usual
there's no proof the giggle pig is a
serious problem so we're just supposed
to wait until it turns into an epidemic
you're like the league of nations in 36
just hoping the abyssinian
that's the lesson you draw from the fall
of arasa baba you sound so naive and you
sound just like victor emmanuel iii
i have no idea who's winning
me neither terry
how serious a threat do you really think
giggle pig poses very serious or it
could be nothing or it could be the new
crack the new crack it's new crack
that was amazing we got a task force
more importantly once you got served
once sounds like lunch
oh this opens up so many new avenues
you better make some big arrests and
quick or you'll be the poster boy for
departmental waste slam dunk
returned
now if we make those arrests
three-point dunk
you guys really don't know enough about
basketball to be doing this
good luck you're gonna need it
yes we all need luck thank you for
offering me some
[Laughter]
contestants must make it past the
barricade
beanbag gun to get a snack
you will eat the snacks in its entirety
next head down to the first locate a
pamphlet about bullying then print out a
picture of me using a laptop from 1982.
perhaps their printout first is the
winner
[Applause]
[Music]
the elements
how smart and smart
[Music]
santiago
peralta
boyle
hitchcock is very handsome
well thank you boyle
[Music]
it's a bunch of dumb contests we play to
kill the time nobody even cares who wins
i won
because you're afraid that jake and i
are gonna cut you out well you're not
wrong i'm gonna find that tape you think
i'd just leave something that valuable
lying around
i got it on me
oh give me that carrot oh
no
i let amy win
you're right
i'm not over her
do you stuff the pair two hundred
dollars yeah probably
i think those are gonna let that go
it is not like you to get hung up on a
girl
i don't know what to do you call katie
that's what you do
oh
let's move on whether you think you're
ready to or not gotta get out there man
the john method always moving on banging
banging banging especially during the
pandemic
peralta and santiago were cowards diaz
was disrespectful and i just saw
hitchcock and boyle fighting like
children
[Laughter]
everyone else made this watch lunch
connection instantly the task force is
risky but it gives us a chance to do a
lot of good in the community if you ask
me
you're acting like a real victor
emmanuel iii you used that insult
completely incorrectly
[Laughter]
that's why i think rosa should leave the
task force
there's no bs with her
agreed thank you sergeant
and
i know you were lying about that lunch
orange thing
that was mine
[Laughter]
yep well thanks for getting the tape
back
oh
gosh
i'll see you tonight at my place god i
hate you don't be late
not a doctor
there's so much to deconstruct
about the political undertones of this
episode you know task forces
police funding
uh you know the rampant rise of new
kinds of drugs in our communities across
these united states i'm glad that
someone has
the massive testicles to cover these
issues as well as other things you know
like uh like revenge porn you know and
uh you know people's personal
video and photographic footage you know
being exploited to get them to do things
for you know a personal gain
there's a lot of heavy crimes in this
episode and uh you know justice i think
by the end of it was ultimately served
so uh this episode of csi was great
really loved all the investigating and
uh yeah they should bring it back you
know in las vegas this time
not like the first time where it was in
las vegas
this is segwayed into a wonderful csi
vegas joke
because uh that's what was on my mind at
the time
uh no this is a really funny episode uh
i wonder if jimmy jams is gonna become
another one of those uh you know like
every season or two kind of you know
like things we have to look forward to
and i think i think this is a there's a
hot scoop
uh from i think the patreon comments or
maybe even the youtube comments but i i
think
when rosa steps up to the desk and she's
in her disguise she starts to talk to
the guy before she goes back to her rosa
voice i've heard it said that whenever
she does like a silly
you know like mock girl voice she's
actually just using her natural voice
or something much more akin to her
natural voice and then you know her rosa
uh character is much more you know like
did low register so i thought it was
very funny to actually see that for the
first time i think it's time we
break the veil
oh no
why what are we doing no we can't we
can't
no
oh no
from three years ago just the audio for
a second this will be good
this will be good i'm gonna test your
honesty whoever told me that
don't edit this out i want youtube's
loading
something like parks and rec something
like parks and rec i want something like
parks and rec and then when pilot season
came which is this
i don't know if you guys know anything
about tv but it's basically like january
february is when they're casting all the
new shows and television and it's kind
of shifted a little bit like some of the
auditions happen earlier or later
so split the difference
that doesn't sound that different
well
now we know
now we know
it was a lot funner in the comment form
when i was like oh
she talks he probably has a really high
pitched voice he probably has a cartoon
voice
no but uh yeah i thought there were a
lot of fun bits in this episode a lot of
fun bits
uh
i'm happy for amy even though i wish she
had one of her own uh you know
prowess at the game
and not been allowed to win you're
really breaking this whole episode uh
you know boyle and uh hitchcock man what
a what a folly ado what a folly ado
shared between hitchcock and uh boyle
uh
you know terry and terry and holt always
a good combo i'm enjoying the addition
of lunch into you know just the
getting sprinkled into the ensemble
you know
and uh you know shouts out to my man
scully at some point he's gonna he's got
the operatic pipes and i appreciate that
that's probably just a real skill he has
that almost never gets used and then
they were like hey we'll just use it for
this character
yeah man these are all my stray
observations this is really good this is
this is what the people don't want to
see the reaction they just want the
review they want the in-depth and break
down the 20 minutes of comedy we just
watched
i wonder if andy's gonna or if jake's
actually gonna go on that date
and if we'll see it yeah man dude
it's not cool
don't know what i mean man nothing's
cool you know what i mean just kind of
we gotta move on you gotta move on man
you know you can't get hung up on
anyone [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
man i just can't get humble [ __ ] yeah
i'm [ __ ] man
[ __ ] just hold you back all these
[ __ ] out here they hold you back yeah
man they're just big digging digging in
your pockets and holding you down yeah
dude yeah
yeah [ __ ] man they dig in your
pockets and then replace it with just
with emotional rocks with emotional
stones weight just stones stones of
emotion
don't have pants anymore because the
rocks falling down haven't pulled your
pants down and then you fall into the
ground because you tripped over your
pants around your ankle and they get
your pants back yeah and they're too
heavy to pull up it starts with the
pants
and then you can't do it man so you just
gotta you know [ __ ] you just gotta
move on yeah yeah just bang bang around
bang bang bang bang it's this song with
something from bang bang this is this is
that song man dude bang bang
i
banged a girl bang bang
across the world bang bang
really hot girl big fan bang this baby
yeah yeah that's what the original song
was about yeah man banging
what that's where the slang terms come
misconstrued though it went really out
of style for many years and then came
back i mean what jake needs to do is
move to a different precinct
or a different city altogether he was
gone for six months undercover
pretending to be someone else and that
didn't even do the trick having six
months of separation from amy and he
must have had to you know fornicate
during those six months to maintain his
undercover status
as a mafioso
because we know people in the mob love
vices
such as lustful pursuits
yes i don't know why these are the words
i'm choosing today they're just that's
just what's happening oh no man there's
no thought or design to any of this it's
all random it's chaos no one ever
bothered to ask if we should
they only bothered to ask if we could
yeah
jeff goldblum jeff goldblum man the fly
that's good
which i mean it applies it still applies
to that movie too so it's
good anything any other stray
observations nah dude i think i covered
it all i think we covered everybody well
i covered we didn't mention gina
gina's cool you know
this whole charles and gina plot line's
pretty fun i would hate to get involved
in a
sexual entanglement with gina it seems
like it would be a a lot of work
you can't get out of that you want to
yeah it seems like it would be a uh uh
yeah like a honey trap
like you would you know
you'd be like like fly tape you'd be
like trying to get out and you're like
stuck and you're like ah come on yes sir
your energy is really low hey
like i am too high energy right now i
need to bring it down to the negative
notches do some music playing on this
room
[Music]
yeah usually to match your low sad
energy that you got i'm gonna put some
sad dramatic music under
it's gonna be like a moving but epic and
uh yeah a very emotional score and
people who listen and they'll be like
can i get a version of this without the
talking just get the emotional
underscore
keep an eye out for our train to busan
reaction that's going to be fun i'm
pretty sure that video is out already by
the time oh yeah it's sunday guys go
back and watch our train to busan
reaction
keep an eye out for it if you haven't
seen it yet and then go search it and
then you'll be rewarded instantly for
having kept that eye out
subscribe like and comment we're not
done no
we'll drop those hot takes man all right
what did you hate about this episode
uh you know
uh
it uh there's a couple jokes that didn't
land for me um
and uh i just thought those some of the
shows could be funnier can't afford that
in the comedy i'm embodying my favorite
guests right now
best guess i've ever brought on this
channel
do they have names
you get a shotgun
i got faces in my mind
oh i'm excited
now i'm trying to see if i can guess
i'm just like yeah
all right guys i'm done with my little
schtick uh yeah that was just nine
minutes of commitment right
i'm sorry
i thought that was a
really funny episode and um
i'm really liking what they're doing
with holt because he's usually the one
who becomes the most like uh
uh
back to center
and he's just not
rivalry
hit right down to the wire nothing can
let him really see past
this uh this is this little game that
he's mixed up in he's just even right
down to the like
the lunch lunch
yeah
that's uh this is so hilarious
um
yeah i mean the games are um very
inconsiderate i found myself actually
getting uh kind of upset
you know in a way of like man guys
there's a bunch of cuts happening right
now and uh this is very irresponsible
behavior yeah
i lost sight of the comedy and got
pulled into the realism
you imagined what it would be like lives
matter in that moment
you you imagined what it would be like
to be another cop in that precinct
trying to work while these idiots run
around in bomb suits
and eat old chinese food
normally i don't like to film when i'm
this tired and uncontrollable
it's more fun when you're slap happy
you're more slap happy i'm very more
wonderful
more it's been
yeah i've been too hard to sleep
so much
here was the plan the plan was let's
watch brooklyn and wake us up
and i was like that was funny but now
it's done i'm like oh crap and trash
those laughs didn't help they only
helped in the moment
they helped me make it through the
episode without falling asleep
it's like when you wake up in the
morning and check your phone and you get
a little bit of that endorphin rush
from just like reading notifications or
something [ __ ] you know and your neurons
firing
because of all the
electrical waves
stimulating your brain yeah that's why
they say don't check your phone in the
morning because of all that
and then you're like awake now and then
uh and then when you're away from it
you're like aw crap now
tractor beam i'm back
i'm back
okay we'll go get your phone get your
phone and wake up get your dopamine who
is the grip
oh hey
what's up
all right guys listen
so
are you gonna are you gonna read some
texts we have this friend named brandon
[Laughter]
and
he came to see venom with us and then
let them recarnage
and he was like i didn't see the last
one he's like i'm not gonna lie i
haven't seen a spider-man movie since
toby mcguire
yes so i was like dude there's no way i
can catch you up
you just have to go in and just roll
with it and now he's coming to halloween
kills and he hasn't seen any of the
halloween movies any of them at all no
and so i i was like here's a link where
you can watch the first halloween he's
like no i'm good kill it with a knife
got it
he was coming to these sequels he came
in godzilla versus like no i haven't
seen the man i've never seen a godzilla
right there lizard monkey got it
yes got enough cool alien spider got it
nope two aliens man two aliens
whatever
kill with a knife
[Laughter]
like mythology only brandon could roll
over the movie like that and be like no
i understand everything yeah yeah she's
not his sister and there you
i'm just go it's literally picking up
moments after the last one yet no
worries cut
no well hopefully they'll still put a
last time on halloween
montage for people like him
yeah
just in case no one's seen it
just in case no one's seen one of the
most prolific slasher films of all time
and it's subsequent
uh spawn
we should bring brandon in for a
reaction
for like a season five episode of
brooklyn nine-nine come on
come on no way home league yes yeah just
be like hey how do you feel what's going
on who's andrew garfield what's a tom
holland
at the end of the post-credits scene
invented he really was like who's that
guy
um
guys subscribe to brandon
call him brian and melinda brandon
milgar follow him on the internet
blow up his instagram
with out of context halloween details
all right guys
uh we should do a patreon let's do a
patreon of the day shout out
chris wham off i've got this chris
wham-off you've been elected elect as
the as the new captain of this precinct
all right because if there's anybody
anybody who's not going to waste the
department of resources
who's going to be looking out for the
community first and foremost it's chris
wham-off plus think of all the
possibilities of the cool one-liners you
could say after busting a perp
you just got whammed
or like whammy
uh you'd probably get accused of
stealing from anchorman if you were to
do whammy but you know it's a start or
like or someone is like
some some guy's like ah yeah i i have my
rights
give me my phone call and he could be
like you could just wham off that's
right
yeah
yeah
then the guy's like oh man i'm i'm hurt
by that
and legally i still get my phone call
and then chris swam off being the good
guy that you are would offer up your own
phone even though you don't have to do
you probably give him his phone get
scared permanently
for the next year yeah i see you guys
like trump's in prison with your phone
using the phone
running his whole operation from your
phone from behind bars because that's
how good you are to people man
send us that money
[Music]